und das gibt uns die gelegenheit schon
mal zu schauen auf die nächsten
tagesordnungspunkt der bärbel bas hier
gleich aufrufen wird es geht nämlich um
die haltung des westens zu zur politik
russlands dazu liegen drei anträge vor
nämlich einmal aus der unionsfraktion
die setzt vor allem auf geschlossenheit
des westens gegenüber russland die
antrag antrag der linken setzt darauf
eine
deeskalation absoluten vorrang zu geben
geben und deswegen auch eine die
bundeswehrsoldaten nach litauen eben
nicht so entfernten und dann gibt es
noch den antrag aus der afg formation
vertrauen schaffen sicherheit
garantieren die afg betont dass es
gespräche auf allen ebenen und in allen
gesprächs formaten für eine friedliche
lösung des konflikts geben müssen also
im grunde das was die bundesregierung ja
schon seit mehreren wochen versucht
unter anderem manifestiert durch die
besucher des bundeskanzlers in moskau
auch die zahlreichen reihen der
bundesaußenminister in annalena baerbock
die jetzt auch auf der regierungsbank
platz genommen hat und der erste redner
in dieser aussprache geht johann david
wadephul sein stellvertretender
vorsitzender der unions-fraktion
aus russland die krim rechtswidrig
annektierte und in einem hybriden ansatz
bewaffnete konflikte im osten der
ukraine initiierte die bis heute
andauern nicht vorstellen können
russische streitkräfte in einem ausmaß
dass sie ohne weiteres in der lage sind
nach wie vor bedauerlicherweise
die ukraine zu überfallen dort eine
militärische invasion durchzuführen
befinden sich an den grenzen dieses
zweitgrößten europäischen
landes das modell einer ukraine die
demokratisch parlamentarisch
funktioniert der freie presse und freie
gerichte gibt wird von der russischen
führung offensichtlich als bedrohung
angesehen
friedrich merz hatte in der letzten
debatte hier schon darauf hingewiesen
welche entwicklung ist in russland
gegeben habt nach dem premier putin hier
noch 2001 im westen eine zusammenarbeit
anbot die wir auch nicht vollständig
angenommen haben hat er 2008 auf der
münchner sicherheitskonferenz
dem zusammenbruch der sowjetunion als
die größte katastrophe des zwanzigsten
jahrhunderts bezeichnet hier sieht man
offenkundig die motive der russischen
führung das ist nur eine erklärung keine
legitimierung und keine legalisierung
des russischen vorgehens was wir in und
um die ukraine sehen einem solchen
vorgehen was russland seit 2014 in der
ukraine zeigt und was es jetzt wieder an
droht durch diese truppen massierung
muss sich die freie welt entgegen stehen
hier muss deutschland gemeinsam mit
unseren europäischen partnern den
vereinigten staaten für frieden für die
einhaltung der regelbasierten ordnung
und für die internationale rechtsordnung
einstehen
in diesem
sinne hat die bundesregierung in den
letzten wochen gehandelt danke der
außenministerin ausdrücklich auch für
ihre reise an die kontakt linie für ihre
reise nach kiew für ihre klaren aussagen
dort ich danke auch den bundeskanzler
der jetzt in kiew und dann auch im
beisein von vladimir putin nach einem
ausführlichen gespräch klargemacht hat
dass deutschland dieses verhalten nicht
akzeptiert dass wir gemeinsam
geschlossen mit den vereinigten staaten
mit unseren europäischen partnern wird
die baltischen staaten mit polen mit
allen anrainerstaaten dort
entgegenstehen dieses
verantwortungsvolle handeln der
bundesregierung unterstützt die cdu csu
bundestagsfraktion
wir haben allerdings zu der form des
vorgehens und zu ihrer kommunikation
anmerkung zu machen und die erste
anmerkung ist das fehlen des
bundeskanzlers in dieser debatte
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren es
droht nicht weniger als krieg und dem
bundeskanzleramt zu recht in moskau
gesagt es sei die verdammte pflicht
politisch dagegen zu arbeiten aber ich
sage auch in einer parlamentarischen
demokratie wie der bundesrat deutschland
ist es die erste pflicht des
bundeskanzlers herumträgt deutschland
seine politik in dieser krise hier zu
erläutern hier vor dem deutschen
bundestag wo sind sie herr scholz
verkehr deutlich gemacht dass er die
verfassungsordnung kennt und darauf
hingewiesen dass er und nicht gerhard
schröder der aktuelle bundeskanzler ist
aber unser starts verfassungsrecht
regelt ja nicht nur die exekutive und
deren funktionsweise sondern das
parlament
ist der erste ort wo politik erklärt
gerechtfertigt und dargelegt werden muss
ich muss sagen begrüße sehr dass die
frau bundesministerin jetzt hier ist
aber das fehlen des bundeskanzlers ist
nicht zu rechtfertigen und er hätte auch
früher klare worte finden müssen ich
danke an dieser stelle ausdrücklich
bundespräsident frank walter steinmeier
für seine rede auf der bundesversammlung
er hat klar gemacht und es wäre die
aufgabe des bundeskanzlers gewesen wo
deutschland steht
der bundeskanzler ist unklar geblieben
bedauerlicherweise an der seite eines
amerikanischen präsidenten der wie kein
anderer in amerika und angefochten
insbesondere durch die republikaner die
derzeit auch wieder vor dem sprung
stehen mehr einfluss zu bekommen in den
usa der wie kein anderer an der seite
europas steht und betont er will
gemeinsam mit deutschland politik machen
aber sich dorthin zu stellen und es dem
amerikanischen präsidenten zu überlassen
zu klären das nord stream 2 cents
aktionspakete natürlich dazugehört das
war eine situation
das war schon demütigend für den
deutschen bundeskanzler und das hat das
hat den amerikanischen präsidenten der
an unserer seite steht in amerika in
zusätzliche politische schwierigkeiten
gebracht die wir noch einmal bereuen
könnten meine sehr verehrten damen und
herren das war ein großer fehler
und das verhalten gegenüber der ukraine
ist auch rechtfertigungsbedarf tickt
natürlich gehört deutschland nicht zu
den ersten ländern die waffen liefern
das ist doch vollkommen klar dass man
dort zurückhaltung übt ist gute deutsche
tradition aber verstehen wir nicht wie
das für die ukraine wirken muss die sich
einer derartigen militärischen
aggression gegenüber stehen das das
erste was wir ankündigen lazarette sind
verstehen wir nicht dass das in der
ukraine fast als zynisch verstanden wird
und wenn wir dann noch unsere nato
partner die den ersten in den arm fallen
die ein paar veraltete artillerie
systeme liefern wollen meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren das ist keine
position der solidarität mit der ukraine
und das war auch ein großer und das
bleibt ein großer fehler der
bundesregierung
und
vizekanzler arbeit muss man sagen wer
als parteivorsitzender defensivwaffen
für richtig hält der darf sich wenn er
dann ein staatsamt haben hat nicht ein
schweigegelübde auferlegen das passt
nicht zu seinem politischen anspruch den
wir von ihnen kennen der bundeskanzler
hat zu recht gesagt die souveränität der
ukraine ist unantastbar aber auch die
entscheidung der ukraine und des
bündnisses selber irgendwann über einen
eintritt der ukraine in die nato zu
entscheiden muss unantastbar bleiben
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen das sage
ich nicht nur mit blick auf die ukraine
das steht nicht auf der tagesordnung das
sage ich auch komme aus
schleswig-holstein ostseeanrainer mit
blick auf schweden und finnland wird
dürfen uns von russland nicht
vorschreiben lassen wer sich unseren
defensiven friedlichen bündnissen
anschließt das muss klare deutsche
position sein
und ein wort zu russland abschließend
wird durch märz hat öffentlich
richtigerweise gesagt russland ist nicht
unser feind das glaube ich verstehen wir
auch alle hier so insbesonders russische
volk steht uns eher nahe aufgrund einer
langen historie und langen kulturellen
beziehungen durch den letzten krieg hat
deutschland eine besondere verantwortung
dass das russische volk nicht erneut in
kriegerische handlungen verstrickt wird
aber auch das ukrainische volk und dort
haben die schlimmsten kriegshandlungen
der deutschen wehrmacht im zweiten
weltkrieg stattgefunden wir müssen in
der lage sein zwischen den russischen
volk und denjenigen die die führung dort
haben einer kleptokraten clique zu
unterscheiden wir stehen an der seite
des russischen volkes wir sind ein
freund russlands und gerade deutschland
bei alle realpolitik die natürlich
verlangt mit der regierung zu verhandeln
muss beachten wir haben viel schuld auf
uns geladen in russland und wir sind dem
russischen volk und dem kubanischen volk
verpflichtet jeden einsatz für frieden
in dieser region zu leisten herzlichen
dank für die aufmerksamkeit
wie johann wadephul stellvertretender
vorsitzender der unions-fraktion
vermisst den bundeskanzler in dieser in
debatte im deutschen bundestag zur
haltung des westens zur politik
russlands
bundestagspräsidentin begrüßt den
ukrainischen botschafter in dieser
sekunde mal gucken ob die kolleginnen
und kollegen an den kameras in gleich
noch einfangen ich wollte sagen johann
wadephul vermisst den kanzler in der
debatte an erkennt allerdings die
aktivitäten und gespräche der
bundesregierung und spricht von einem
verantwortungsvollen handeln der nächste
redner kommt wie johann wadephul aus
schleswig holstein ist ralf stegner dem
wir seit vielen jahren neben der politik
kennen und hält hier trotzdem seine
erste rede im bundestag
nicht auf dem user gruppenfoto meine
fraktion dabei sein durfte und auch
nicht zur senkung des alters netz in
diesem hause beitrage ist es meine erste
rede als mitglied des deutschen
bundestags das ist für mich eine große
ehre und dann geht es gleich um den
frieden in europa neben der kommune
krise steht unsere koalition vor einer
ersten großen bewährungsprobe
der massive russische militär aufmarsch
ukrainische grenzen und die spannung in
den letzten wochen bedrohen den frieden
in einer weise wie kaum einer von uns
für möglich gehalten hätte und in dieser
situation kommt die neue
oppositionsfraktion mit einem antrag
daher der mich dann doch wieder in die
user zeiten zurück führt das was sie
zusammen geschrieben haben in ihrem
papier werde kollegin kollegen von der
union ist der retro sound alle wege
führen nach moskau da passt es ins bild
wenn der kollege plus unsere minister
bei seinem manuela schwesig diffamiert
nur weil sie seine meinung nicht teilt
es fehlen nur noch die vaterlandslose
gesellen in dem antrag wenn man auf
ihren antrag wenn da nicht obendrauf
zwanzigste wahlperiode stehen würde herr
oppositionsführer könnte man meinen es
stammt aus ihrer ersten amtszeit was da
steht ich will einen satz daraus
zitieren denen sie aber nicht an die
bundesregierung richten sollten sondern
an sich selbst der nämlich heißt ich
fordere sie auf ihrer gefährlichen
schlingerkurs in der außenpolitik zu
beenden der bayerische ministerpräsident
hat sich nämlich ganz anders geäußert
als ich das in ihrem gemeinsamen antrag
von cdu und csu hier eingebracht haben
aber bei herrn söder ist ja
wahrscheinlich eine frage der zeit was
gerade gilt was eine position angeht nun
mag man ihn lieber kollege wadephul ihre
rollen findung zugute halten aber wenn
sie gestern mit uns gegen
waffenlieferungen heute für waffen
liefern sind wofür sind sie dann
eigentlich morgen und ich muss ihnen
ehrlich sagen wenn es um krieg und
frieden geht ist solche schaukelpolitik
gefährlich zum glueck sitzen weder herr
merz
im außerdem anderen kanzleramt sondern
olaf scholz und annalena baerbock und
das ist gut so
gute außenpolitik braucht
verlässlichkeit ist die clean und ein
felsenfest das wertefundament genau das
haben der bundeskanzler und sie frau
außenministerin in den letzten wochen in
kiew in moskau in brüssel in washington
vorzüglich bewiesen herzlichen dank
dafür übrigens der bundeskanzler ist
entschuldigt weil er die baltischen
staaten gerade informiert über seine
gespräche in moskau
einigkeit der alliierten zurückhaltung
bei den razzien kommunikation und geduld
wird demokratie über die
professionalität könnte es auch dazu
dass diplomatie nicht in interviews
betrieben wird und hinter verschlossenen
türen die schachspieler unter ihnen
sollten wir uns zu wissen wer die
nächsten fünf züge vorher an können
nicht mehr verliert wahrscheinlich die
partie das ist nicht schlau transparent
ja aber nicht laut
bundeskanzler scholz hat im sinne einer
werte basierten und realitätsbezogen
außen und sicherheitspolitik genau das
richtige gesagt für uns in deutschland
und europa kann es nachhaltige
sicherheit nicht gegen russland solo mit
russland geben entsprechend hat sich
über uns auch der französische
staatspräsident hat im koalitionsvertrag
heißt es eine konsistente und
europäische politik gegenüber russland
muss die unterschiedlichen positionen
von bedrohungen einbeziehen rolf
mützenich hat recht man muss die
russischen positionen nicht teilen um
diese perspektiven nachvollziehen zu
können natürlich haben sich die
verhältnisse geändert gegenüber der
ostpolitik von willy brandt und walter
scheel was ich aber nicht geändert hat
eine geschichte und geografie in den
letzten tagen war auch von den richtigen
lehren die rede die wir zu ziehen hätten
deutschland hat den zweiten weltkrieg
angezettelt halb europa verwüstet und
war verantwortlich für das monströse
verbrechen des holocaust mit millionen
von opfern in polen russland der ukraine
und in vielen anderen ländern nach 1945
wurden wir wieder in die völkerfamilie
aufgenommen und wir haben wie kein
anderes land von frieden in europa
profitiert natürlich müssen wir
verantwortung für sicherheit und frieden
übernehmen aber es kann doch nicht
heißen dass deutschland waffenlieferant
in krisengebiete wird meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren nein
deutschland hat eine andere rolle wir
müssen mehr als jeder andere für frieden
kämpfen wir müssen hier mehr als jeder
andere die ukraine wirtschaftlich
unterstützen wir müssen mehr als jeder
andere film liefert über rost ze bis zum
ende alles aber auch wirklich alles
dafür tun dass die diplomatie erfolg hat
das heißt ausgleich berechtigter
interessen auf der basis von
menschenrechten demokratie souveränität
und territoriale integrität der staaten
europas die bundesregierung handelt
geeint und im einklang mit unserer
verbündeten joe biden hat bei der
pressekonferenz mit olaf scholz in
washington gesagt dass es keinerlei
zweifel an der zuverlässigkeit der
deutschen bundesregierung gehen was sagt
der oppositionsführer das zeige die
zweifel in der deutschen bundesregierung
ich bewundere ja dialektischen
fähigkeiten der kollege merz will gar
nicht wissen was sie gesagt haben herr
beiden das nicht erwähnt hätte
wahrscheinlich das gegenteil es ist doch
klar sollte es zu einer militärischen
eskalation kommen müsste russland einen
hohen preis zahlen dann würden die
westlichen alliierten gemeinsam schnell
geeint und handeln aber bevor nichts
mehr geht heißt es auch für uns immer
wieder lieber 100 stunden umsonst
verhandeln als einige minuten schießen
das hat übrigens ein kluger
sozialdemokratische altkanzler gesagt
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
bundeskanzler olaf scholz hat in moskau
zur frage eine nato mitgliedschaft der
ukraine betont diese frage stehe auf
absehbare zeit nicht auf der
tagesordnung und es geht darum
pragmatische lösungen zu finden die
beide seiten tragen können ohne die
grundsätze aufzugeben so hat es schon f
kennedy klugerweise der kuba krise
gehalten das war die logik der us
politik und das gilt auch heute wenn es
um frieden und krieg in europa geht's
den antrag der union werden wir ablehnen
ja lieber olaf scholz ist es unsere
verdammte pflicht für den frieden
einzutreten oder welches vorgänger willy
brandt formuliert hat der frieden ist
nicht alles aber ohne frieden ist alles
nichts
ralf stegner war das mit seiner ersten
rede im deutschen bundestag
und er hat sie gehalten in der debatte
in der es gibt eben diese haltung des
westens zur politik große anfrage hervor
um 11 uhr den wahlgang schließen also
sollte jemand hier noch im raum sein
oder im hause dann
schnell
und der wahlgang beschäftigt sich mit
dem sondergremium zum
stabilisierungsmechanismus gesetz
das war noch mal der hinweis eben von
bundestagspräsident in bars alexander
gauland ist auf dem weg zum pult
früher mal in der letzten
legislaturperiode vorsitzender co
vorsitzender der fdp fraktion jetzt
mitglied im auswärtigen ausschuss
frau präsidentin meine damen und herren
stellen wir uns einmal vor wir schreiben
das jahr 2040 und kanada hätte aus
wirtschaftlichen gründen einer näherung
ein china vollzogen und sei bereit eine
militär konvention abzuschließen und der
chinesischen flotte eine basis auf neue
kunden zur verfügung zu stellen wäre die
usa noch eine großmacht würde sie die
monroe doktrin aufrufen und deutlich
machen dass eine fremde macht auf dem
amerikanischen kontinent mit den
sicherheitsinteressen der usa
unvereinbar ist
wahrscheinlich würde china die usa
darauf hinweisen dass kanada souverän
und frei sei die wahl seiner
militärbündnisse selbst zu bestimmen und
die halo friedliche absichten hege
großen eindruck wurde dieses argument in
amerika wohl kaum machen denn es ist das
eine nach dem völkerrecht ein
theoretisches recht zu haben und das
andere in einer staaten ordnung wie sie
nun einmal ist und auch bleiben wird
seinen platz mit klugheit zu behaupten
auch wenn das ungerecht erscheint malta
und china sind nun einmal nicht gleich
von gewicht und macht und daher ist es
zur malta notwendiger als für china
seine außenbeziehungen möglichst
geschmeidig zu gestalten dazu gehört
eben auch
mächtigen nachbarn nicht unnötig zu
reizen
die ukraine ist für russland kein
x-beliebiges land sondern zeilen einer
gemeinsamen vergangenheit
wurzeln in einer gemeinsamen identität
und auch geopolitisch ist besser in
fremder oder gar feindlicher hand für
russland nur schwer erträglich ist es
doch das unersetzliche tor für den
handel mit dem mittelmeerraum es geht
hier nicht um werte oder ideologie oder
regierungsform sondern um interessen es
geht um geopolitik was haben wir
deutschen lager verlernt deshalb wäre es
klug lösungen zu finden
die für die großmacht russland annehmbar
und für die ukraine akzeptabel sind
eine nato-mitgliedschaft dieses landes
ist es nicht wohl aber ein wie auch
immer garantierter neutraler status wie
in unterschiedlicher weise finnland und
österreich genießen
auch in der außenpolitik
kann manchmal ein weniger ein mehr sein
und eine gesicherte existenz zwischen
den fronten
heilsamer als ein unendlicher konflikt
ja eh keiner hat das recht ihre
bündnisse frei zu wählen doch wie sie da
von dem angesicht ihrer nachbarn
gebrauch macht
entscheidet über erfolg und misserfolg
des noch jungen staatswesens
deshalb sollte der westen alles
vermeiden diese krise zum instrument
eines billigen triumphes über russland
zu machen und der ukraine dringend
abraten
geopolitisch teil des westens zu werden
auf dauer ist
eine europäische friedensordnung nur mit
russland und niemals gegen seine
interessen zu verwirklichen den
cdu-antrag werden wir deshalb natürlich
ablehnen der antrag der linken werden
wir uns enthalten denn er enthält
wichtige elemente ich bedanke mich
alexander gauland war das für die fdp
fraktion und im vg zehnjähriger bruder
schon mit ihrer zweiten rede heute
vormittag im deutschen bundestag sie ist
ja stellvertretende vorsitzende der
fraktion bündnis 90 die grünen für die
fraktion bündnis 90/die grünen agnieszka
broker
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen vor 20 jahren
am 8 februar 2002 lief in der tagesschau
folgende meldung ich zitiere mit
erlaubnis der präsidentin präsident
putin lob bei einem treffen cdu-chefin
merkel die guten deutsch russischen
beziehungen für einen beitritt russlands
zur nato sei die zeit nicht reif
was weiß die gesicht erscheint es alles
so unfassbar weit weg viel weiter weg
als 20 jahre denn in diesen tagen müssen
wir uns ernsthaft die frage stellen ob
der gleiche wladimir putin kurz davor
ist ein befehl zu einem militärischen
großangriff auf unsere freunde in der
ukraine zu geben ein befehl der viele
verletzte und tote zur folge hätte und
da wird das internationale recht sehr
schnell nicht theoretisch sondern sehr
konkret ein solcher angriff er wäre aber
auch eine attacke auf unsere gemeinsam
vereinbarte friedensordnung auf unserem
gemeinsamen kontinent wenn wir jetzt
aber zurück schauen was in diesen 20
jahren passiert ist dann gehört
sicherlich auch die selbstkritische
frage dazu ob nicht auch von seiten der
europäischen staaten der usa der nato
chancen versäumt und fehler begangen
würden war es immer wichtig wie wir auf
russische gesprächsangebote reagiert
haben haben wir sie vielleicht manchmal
zu früh abgetan war es klug als
präsident obama russland als
regionalmacht verspottet hat und hat uns
der streit um die raketenabwehr am ende
unterm strich wirklich mehr sicherheit
gebracht aber meine damen und herren
nichts davon
rechtfertigt auch nur ansatzweise das
was wir in den letzten jahren beobachten
müssen denn völkerrechts bruch mit der
annexion der krim den krieg in der ost
ukraine und nun die aufrüstung und
drucken konzentration in belarus im
schwarzen meer und an den grenzen der
ukraine
und wo wir waren wirklich auch die frage
war nur ob die alte bundesregierung in
den letzten jahren nicht zu wenig klar
und nicht konsequent genug war als wir
eigentlich schon lange erkennen mussten
und konnten das wladimir putin eine
demokratie zu einer autokratie umbaut
dass er nicht davor zurückschreckt
mutige stimmen für die freiheit mundtot
zu machen und seine machtansprüche immer
wieder eiskalt mit militärischen mitteln
durchsetzt diese aggression im inneren
und nach außen des kreml der letzten
jahren sie sind auch kein ausdruck von
stärke sondern sie stehen für eine
antwort der angst angst vor werten die
freiheit selbstbestimmung und demokratie
und ihrer strahlkraft
meine damen und herren ich bin es auch
wirklich leid immer wieder von der
ukraine krise zu lesen diese krise ist
nicht von der ukraine mit verursacht sie
ist auch nicht von der nato ausgelöst
sondern sie ist das ergebnis russische
aggression es ist der versuch
ist er versucht mit
militärpolitische einfluss wären über
die köpfe unserer mittel und
osteuropäischen partner hinweg
durchzusetzen eine solche haltung die
die rechte unserer freunde mit füßen
tritt und unsere gemeinsame europäische
friedensordnung zerstört der werden wir
uns gemeinsam entschieden
entgegenstellen und vor diesem
hintergrund wird unsere solidarität mit
der ukraine nur noch größer nehmen wir
die sorgen unserer mittel und
osteuropäischen partner nur umso ernster
daher ist es richtig die präsenz in
litauen zu verstärken und die
wirtschaftliche sicherheitspolitische
unterstützung für die ukraine weiter
auszubauen und frau ministerin ich
möchte ihnen auch danken dass sie in
dieser schwierigen lage nicht nur
beschlossen haben das deutsche personal
in der osze mission zu belassen sondern
dass sie jetzt sogar prüfen es zu
verstärken ich glaube dass dies ein
wichtiges zeichen
ich danke ihnen und dem bundeskanzler
das sind all diese werte all diese
überzeugungen das internationale recht
mit klarheit verteidigt haben auf ihren
reisen sie zu recht in kiew und nicht in
moskau begann und in so vielen
gesprächen und begegnungen mit unseren
verbündeten in europa und über den
atlantik hinweg mit ebenso großer
klarheit lässt die bundesregierung aber
auch keinen zweifel daran dass eine
weitere russische aggression und ein
erneuter militärischer angriff auf die
ukraine mit sehr harten wirtschaftlichen
und politischen sanktionen beantwortet
wird und dass dabei alles auf dem tisch
liegt ja auch nord stream 2 der kreml
würde und müsste eine solche attacke
bitter bereut und
meine damen und herren diese drohung die
steht nicht im raum um zu eskalieren
sondern sie steht im raum um die gefahr
abzuwenden und dafür zu sorgen dass die
konflikte und sie sind groß mit worten
und nicht mit waffen ausgetragen wird
unsere einigkeit und unsere
entschiedenheit
das sind unsere größten stärken in
dieser auseinandersetzung und einer der
größten gefallen bieten wir bloody mir
putin tun könnten wäre sie zu zerreden
und uns spalten zu lassen und diesen
gefallen dürfen wir ihm nicht tun
leider können wir noch keine echte
entspannung der lage beobachten die
situation sie bleibt brandgefährlich und
es ist jetzt an präsident putin
glaubwürdige belege für den
angekündigten truppenabzug zu liefern
leider lesen wir heute von anderen
hinweis aber wir nehmen auch sehr
aufmerksam war wenn er bei der
pressekonferenz mit bundeskanzler scholz
ankündigt über die antworten und
kooperationsangebote die die nato
gemacht hat für ein echtes mehr an
sicherheit für transparenz für
rüstungskontrolle
es sprechen zu wollen das gespräch dazu
es wird ganz sicher nicht von unserer
seite abreißen
meine damen und herren in russland leben
und über 100 144 millionen menschen mit
denen wir in guter nachbarschaft leben
wollen zu ihnen gehören aber auch die
kritische journalistin die nachfragen
stellt um korruption aufdeckt der bürger
hat er bei unregelmäßigkeiten bei der
wahl auf die straße gehen der
mitarbeiter der renommierten
menschenrechtsorganisation memorial die
verboten wurde und wir wissen
langfristige sicherheit in europa kann
es nicht gegen sondern nur mit russland
geben aber auf der basis des
völkerrechts und der menschenrechte ist
gebe so viele wichtige themen wie
klimaschutz rüstungskontrolle globale
gesundheit wo wir eigentlich
zusammenarbeiten könnten und mussten so
weit unsere hand zur kooperation mit den
menschen in russland ausgestreckt ist so
hart werden aber die konsequenzen sein
wenn präsident putin unsere europäische
friedensordnung unsere freundinnen und
freunde in der ukraine angreift und
andere staaten bedroht das ist unsere
klare gemeinschaft gemeinsame botschaft
über den atlantik hinweg und aus der
mitte europas hinaus vielen dank
an hersteller stellvertretende
vorsitzende der fraktion bündnis 90 die
grünen mit ihren anmerkungen zum thema
haltung des westens zur politik
russlands
die zeit ist nämlich jetzt
abgelaufen ich frage trotzdem gibt es
noch ein anwesendes mitglied im haus das
ist noch nicht gewählt hat
das ist nicht der fall
dann schließe ich die wahlen und bitte
die schriftführerin und schriftführer
mit der auszählung zu beginnen das
ergebnis der wahlen wird ihnen dann
später bekannt gegeben
jetzt kommen wir zurück zur debatte
nächster redner für die fraktion die
linke linke dr gregor gysi
und gregory ist der außenpolitische
sprecher seiner fraktion der
linksfraktion
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen es ist immer die rede von der
gefahr des ersten heißen krieges nach
ende des kalten krieges in europa aber
das ist falsch den ersten heißen krieg
für sie die nato gegen serbien und zwar
auch noch völkerrechtswidrig wir sind
uns aber einig dass es keinen zweiten
heißen krieg in europa geben darf die
regierung verlässt sich gerne auf
informationen der us geheimdienste ich
mich nicht ich erinnere daran der grund
für den irak krieg laut us
geheimdiensten und übrigens mit hilfe
auch noch das bnd bestand darin dass ihr
akku und daher ihnen über
massenvernichtungswaffen verfügte später
wurden wir hatten keine das heißt der
letzte krieg die ganze begründung war
unglaubwürdig und völkerrechtswidrig und
jetzt haben die usa geheimdienste gesagt
das bis gestern die russischen truppen
einmarschieren werden in der ukraine
sie sind aber nicht einmarschiert ich
glaube mein misstrauen ist berechtigter
als ihr fester glaube an diese
geheimnisse sie werfen russland einer
völkerrechtsverletzungen durch die
annexion der krim vor das stimmt zu
recht deshalb gibt es ja auch die
tiefgreifende sanktionen gegen russland
nur die zwei von mir genannten krieger
einmal von der nato und einmal von einem
wichtigen mitglied der nato bamberger
rechtswidrig es gibt die resolution ein
traum 244 vom 10 juni 1999 des un
sicherheitsrates das gilt heute noch und
da steht drin dass das kosovo eine hohe
autonomie benötigt aber bestandteil
serbiens bleiben muss und dann hat ihn
hat wird immer gesagt interessiert und
sie mir wir trennen das kosovo ab das
nato mitglied türkei hat nicht nur seine
truppen nahe der grenze aufgestellt von
syrien sondern ist völkerrechtswidrig
einmarschieren natürlich darf b
natürlich darf b nicht stehlen beinahe
schon gestohlen hat aber wie kommen sie
darauf dass sich derart moralisch
meilenweit über b stellen darf die nato
ist nicht der moralische gott gegenüber
russland wegen einer völkerrechts
verletzung nachdem sie selbst oder
mitglieder der nato vorher so oft schon
das völkerrecht verletzt hat
der westen muss bei volker rechtsbruch
keine sanktionen fürchten russland schon
ein gewaltiger unterschied russland
fordert ein sicherheitsabstände den usa
immer zugebilligt wird ich wiederhole
niemals würden den usa schwer bewaffnete
russische soldaten auf kuba und in
mexiko zu lassen warum billigen putin
keinen sicherheitsabstand zu ich
verstehe es nicht und putin steht auch
unter druck und wissen sie auch weshalb
von einem tag zum anderen wurden 27
millionen russinnen und russen beim ist
teil der sowjetunion zur ausländerinnen
und ausländer von einer mehrheit wurden
sie zu einer minderheit und ihnen werden
keine gleichen rechte und keine
chancengleichheit geht fängt schon an
bei der staatsbürgerschaft viele haben
kein wahlrecht und die vorhergehende
regierung hat nicht einmal dafür gesorgt
die diplomatischen beziehungen zu nutzen
um eine chancengleichheit und
gleichberechtigung gerade für diese
russinnen und russen herzustellen das
werfe ich ihr vor wie den anderen
westlichen regierungen aus sie sagen
russland denken in alten kategorien von
ein flusspferd aber es war doch die nato
die entgegen einem versprechen von 1990
14 staaten in ost- und mitteleuropa
aufnahmen also die eigene es wäre
deutlich erweiterte die nato denkt in
den alten block kategorien der besten
gegen russland und china übrigens hat
russland nach herstellung der deutschen
einheit über 100.000 soldaten aus
deutschland abgezogen die
bundesregierung dagegen hat immer mehr
soldaten an andere länder entsandt ich
nenne beispiel 80 liter und mali kosovo
der us politologe john mearsheimer sagt
jetzt die nato hat mit dem feuer
gespielt und sich verbrannt natürlich
kann jedes land im rahmen seiner
souveränität selbst entscheiden ob es
mitglied der nato werden will oder nicht
aber die nato muss ja nicht jedes land
aufnehmen die cdu-forderung nach
geschlossenheit des westens ignoriert
die vorhandenen interessengegensätze
zwischen den usa und europa die usa und
weniger europäische staaten und auch die
grünen wollten ja nie aus dem 2 und man
darf die jetzige situation nicht
missbrauchen um dieses ziel auf anderem
wege zu erreichen
[Applaus]
was die us-partner clean 2 angeht also
wir müssen weg von der konfrontation von
sanktionen von aufrüstung und escalation
wir brauchen das gegenteil europäische
sicherheit gibt es weder ohne noch gegen
russland
tim wiese der außenpolitische sprecher
der fraktion der partei die linke im
deutschen bundestag und sie sehen im
bundestagspräsidium hat es einen wechsel
gegeben jetzt ist katrin göring eckardt
vorsitzende die
bundestags-vizepräsidentin leitet diese
debatte und hat jetzt berichte
aufgerufen so aus der fdp-fraktion er
ist mitglied im auswärtigen ausschuss
meine damen und herren liebe kolleginnen
kollegen von der diktatur zur freiheit
sprich wieder zur sache
wir alle sind ja bestimmt sehr
erleichtert über die letzten
entwicklungen in der russland krise seit
dem besuch von unserem bundeskanzler
scholz und ihr von moskau gibt es erste
zeichen der entspannung die krise ist
damit zwar noch lange nicht vorbei aber
die lage sieht doch weniger bedrohlich
aus als es noch vor wenigen tagen sich
zeigte der vorhergesagte einmarsch von
gestern hat gott sei dank nicht
stattgefunden das zeigt aber auch dass
unser kurs in der russland politik der
richtige war wir haben damit auf das
richtige verhältnis von diplomatie und
abschreckung gesetzt wir haben
gleichzeitig gesprächsbereitschaft und
härte gezeigt denn alle optionen lagen
und liegen auf dem tisch und was am
wichtigsten war wir haben gezeigt dass
wir als nato verbündete zusammenstehen
und uns nicht auseinander treiben lassen
denn das war ja das hauptziel von putin
er wollte tri tra zwischen und seen und
sehen wie weiter damit kommt aber wir
haben ihm die grenzen aufgezeigt wir
haben deutlich gemacht dass seine
forderungen nach angeblichen
sicherheitsgarantien nichts mit
sicherheit zu tun haben herr kollege
gysi sondern völlig aus der zeit
gefallene forderungen nach
einflusssphären sind die mit unseren
heutigen regelbasierten weltordnung
nicht vereinbar sind putin wünscht sich
offenbar eine zeit zurück und
offensichtlich auch die ränder des
hauses in der es noch die sowjetunion
gab und man von moskau aus der sowjet
republiken die politik diktieren konnte
aber diese zeiten sind vorbei
herzlich willkommen im einundzwanzigsten
jahrhundert es ist russland
ausschließlich russland das seine
eigenen sicherheits garantien gegenüber
der ukraine gebrochen hat im budapester
memorandum von 1994 hat sich russland
gegenüber der ukraine
völkerrechtlich verpflichtet die
souveränität und die grenzen der ukraine
zu achten mit der annexion der krim und
der intervention im don basis hat
russland genau diese verpflichtungen
verletzt und das völkerrecht gebrochen
punktum feierabend die ausführung von
putin am dienstag dazu er hätte ein
völkermord verhindern wollen sowie die
donato damals 1 im kosovo sind
hanebüchener geschichtsvergessen sind
wir als freie demokraten sind
bundeskanzler stolz dankbar dass er
diesen protesten aussagen von putin
sofort und unmissverständlich
widersprochen hat meine damen und herren
international stehen wir als nato
verbündete zusammen und haben putin die
grenzen aufgezeigt diese einigkeit
besteht auch weitgehend innenpolitisch
nur am rechten und am linken rand dieses
hohen hauses gibt es ja bekanntlich ein
paar viele putin verstehe da sieht man
erneut den anträgen von afg und linken
und auch am platz verhalten heute die
afg hat keine ahnung von völkerrecht und
die linke möchte die schuld an der
russlandkrise der ukraine und der nato
zu weisen obwohl doch sonnenklar ist
dass russische truppen in der ukraine
stehen und nicht umgekehrt
mit der cdu csu besteht eigentlich
weitgehend einigkeit über die
russlandpolitik zumindestens mit den
fachleuten kollege hat zum beispiel ist
da immer sehr eindeutig aber ich habe
auch am dienstag den kollegen merz so
verstanden der immerhin partei und
fraktionsvorsitzender ist
dass die außenpolitik für die union
eigentlich keinen angriffspunkt für die
oppositionsarbeit sein weil die ampel da
sehr verantwortungsvoll agiert aber
dieser antrag den sie hier und heute
vorlegen ist offenbar von dieser aussage
ihres neuen chefs entstanden weil bis
auf dem titel da sind wir uns ja einig
wird geschlossenheit des westens
entgegentreten gegen die politik
russlands haben wir genau gemacht aber
wenn sie der bundesregierung einen
gefährlichen schlingerkurs vorwerfen
dann verlassen sie selbst diese
geschlossenheit des westens und der nato
am fahren offenbar selbst einen
schlingerkurs
scheinbar müssen sie sich auch hier
grundlegend in der opposition sortieren
und finden aber jetzt sei er unter neuer
führung schauen wir mal das wissen schon
kurzum wir werden alle drei einträge
heute ablehnen die russlandpolitik der
ampel ist gut und richtig und das haben
die letzten tage auch gezeigt viel
übrig ist für die fdp fraktion
verteidigt natürlich die ampel politik
in sachen russland und den herren den
sie da oben auf der besuchertribüne
sehen mit der offensichtlich
gesponserten
atemschutzmaske das ist der botschaft
der ukraine in deutschland andere maniac
jetzt haben sie noch mal eben ganzer
schönheit gesehen jürgen hardt ist der
nächste am rednerpult sprecher für
auswärtige der unionsfraktion
nutzen den einen oder anderen aspekt
anzusprechen der vielleicht dieser
debatte noch nicht zu wort gekommen ist
ich fand es sehr bemerkenswert wie der
kollege rudi lechte für die fdp
einen tiefen und windigen tunnel google
gebot hat um zu sagen um die fdp unserem
antrag nicht zustimmen kann ich glaube
sie hätten sich nichts vertan
dem antrag zuzustimmen denn er ist eine
gute bestandsaufnahme unserer aktuellen
situation mit russland und ein
wirklicher konstruktiver beitrag zur
auseinandersetzung und deswegen glaube
ich dass das ein ausgezeichneter an
dieser debatte
väter bundeskanzler hat sich mit
wichtigen außenpolitischen terminen
entschuldigt ich möchte an dieser stelle
dennoch darauf hinweisen dass wir als
cdu csu bundestagsfraktion
unsere bundeskanzlerin immer dazu
gebracht haben dass sie vor wichtigen eu
gipfeln vor wichtigen politischen
außenpolitische entscheidungen hier vor
dem deutschen bundestag oder zumindest
vor dem europa ausschuss einen
entsprechenden bericht abgibt wir haben
uns damit keine freunde im kanzleramt
gemacht weil das natürlich immer
schwierig ist für die die termine
organisieren müssen aber wir haben es
immerhin gebracht und ich kann sie liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen von der
regierungskoalition nur ermutigen dass
auch bei ihrem kanzler einzuklagen wir
hätten und dieser woche mit sicherheit
einen zeitpunkt befunden wurde der
deutsche bundeskanzler im bundestag über
seine russland-politik rechenschaft
ablegt
ich hätte zum beispiel auf eine frage
zur nord stream das ist ja nun wirklich
in den augen vieler und zwar mittel
osteuropäischen partner total wichtig
der amerikanische präsident hatte in der
pressekonferenz mit olaf scholz in
washington gesagt wenn russland in der
ukraine einmarschiert werden wir das
beenden ich hätte den deutschen
bundeskanzler gerne gefragt war das ein
ergebnis des gesprächs wir olaf scholz
und ich die beiden standen ja da dann
hätte er olaf scholz auch sagen können
christo und wir hätten wurst wo wir
stehen oder war das wir bezogen auf
amerika wir amerika werden dass beenden
dann würde das auf einen dissenz
hinweisen zwischen der deutschen
bundesregierung den deutschen
bundeskanzlerin an bekannten präsidenten
das hätte ich zum beispiel gerne gewußt
allein die frage bleibt jetzt
unbeantwortet jeder mag sich einen reim
drauf dann finde ich in dieser debatte
sehr bemerkenswert zwei gehen wir haben
hier zwei gg sie und deutschland vereint
an der seite russlands gegen den rest
des hauses ich möchte darauf hinweisen
dass wir hier im deutschen bundestag in
der opposition einen eine diametral
unterschiedliche auffassung über die
richtige russland politik haben und dass
wir deshalb so wie es mein kollege war
früher auch dargelegt hat der deutschen
bundesregierung nur viel erfolg und viel
kraft wünschen in dieser schwierigen
zeit für uns alle diese kuh vom eis zu
holen und einen beitrag zur befriedung
der situation zu leisten dann möchte ich
die gelegenheit nutzen noch einmal auf
die wander legende einzugehen die hier
vielfach gerade von den easy eben wieder
vorgetragen wird es hätte eine zusage
gegenüber russland gegeben die nato
würde sich nicht nach osten weiter ich
bitte sie jetzt mal nur mit mir ein
kleines gedankenexperiment
halten sie es wirklich für plausibel
dass der generalsekretär der kp ds und
chef der sowjetunion und sein
außenminister im september 1990 die
vertreter des westens zur seite nimmt
und sagt aber
eins ist ja wohl klar wenn die
sowjetunion
auseinanderbricht oder an einzelne
ehemalige sowjet-republiken
unabhängig werden dann werdet ihr doch
verhindern dass der nato kommen ich
halte das für so absurd dass ein
generalsekretär der kp csu zu diesem
zeitpunkt überhaupt an die möglichkeit
gedacht hätte dass das eintreten könnte
deswegen glaube ich schlicht nicht dass
das überhaupt thema war es ging um aus
deutschland aber es geht eben nicht um
den restmittel aus tripolis hat würden
sie eine zwischenfrage zu lassen aus der
fraktion nein
ich möchte an diesem punkt weiter führen
und sagen warum soll denn der kp
generalsekretär im november 1990 die
charta von paris
unterschreiben wo genau explizit die
freie böten zwar drin steht warum soll
auch ein präsident beziehungsweise
ministerpräsident putin bei jeweiligen
jahrestagen der feierlichkeiten zur
feierlichen unterschreiben von paris
eben genau dieses ergebnis gemeinsamer
europäischer friedenspolitik feiern
anstatt dort an dieser stelle zu
reklamieren dass man eine andere sicht
hat das ist eine komplette umdeutung der
realität die einfach nur sand in die
augen der menschen streuen sollen die
einen realistischen kritischen blick auf
die russlandpolitik haben und den
wollten wir uns als opposition bewahren
und ich kann uns nur alle auffordern
jeden politiker in deutschland jeden
abgeordneten deutschland dass wir uns
diesen kritischen blick bewahren damit
wir europa den frieden bewahren und
nicht ins unglück reisen dankeschön
jürgen hardt sprecher
für
außenpolitik in der unionsfraktion
jetzt kommt peter bis toren aus der afg
fraktion
ja liebe kollegen sie machen hier genau
dasselbe was gestern auch schon n-tv
gemacht hat ja sie stellen eine falsche
frage umgeben sich dann auch diese
falsche frage in der richtige antwort
1990 ging es nicht darum dass man der
sowjetunion versprochen hat er sich
keinen zentimeter weiter
auszudehnen die nato aussen und der us
außenminister baker hat es versprochen
und es ging um uns es ging um
deutschland es ging um unsere deutsche
wiedervereinigung und die amerikaner
haben den rüssel versprochen die nato
wird sich nicht über die grenzen
deutschlands ausweiten dafür gibt es
zeugen professor teltschik und andere
die das bezeugen das ist es ist
protokolliert und das ist ihr
parteifreund also bitte leugnen sie das
nicht die nato hat seit den 14 staaten
aufgenommen das hat der kollege dr giese
hier richtig gesagt also bitte verdrehen
sie hier nicht die geschichte danke
der kollege hat zur erwiderung
ich möchte darauf nur antworten dass ich
bei meiner position bleibe und dass ich
immer wieder in diskussionen
in der öffentlichkeit mit diesem
argument konfrontiert wird und wenn ich
dann sage bitte schickt mir mal per e
mail die belege dafür die angeblichen
videos die es gibt die aussagen die es
gibt ich bekomme keinen eingang es
bleibt eine wander legende
ein kurzes intermezzo zwischen jürgen
halten peter bis 3
dann ist jetzt nächster redner axel
schäfer aus der spd-fraktion mit mit dem
ausschuss für die angelegenheiten der
europäischen union oder kurz
europa-ausschuss
frau präsidentin liebe kollegin kollegen
das wichtigste an dem heutigen tag in
dieser debatte ist dass die sehr große
mehrheit in diesem hause sich einig ist
dass wir alles tun um den frieden in
europa zu erhalten dass wir das
partnerschaft sich tun natürlich mit der
ukraine natürlich auch mit russland und
dass wir das was der bundespräsident
auch am sonntag bei seiner wiederwahl in
unübersehbarer klarheit aus geführt hat
dass das von der großen mehrheit dieses
haus ist hier geteilt wird liebe
kolleginnen und
deshalb auch von meiner seite noch
einmal den dank hier an den
bundeskanzler an die bundes
außenministerin alle die sich in den
letzten tagen wochen monaten immer
wieder engagiert haben was nicht ständig
nur vor kameras sichtbar war und kollege
warte vor und kollege hat ich finde das
auch schon fair und wir haben wir schon
sehr lange auch mit nahezu tun dass sie
das ausdrücklich loben
deshalb verstehe ich auf der anderen
seite nicht die intention
des antrags wo es ja in der ersten zeile
letztendlich darum geht diese politik
wieder zu diskreditieren indem er von
schlingerkurs bricht obwohl wir uns hier
als spd als grüne und fdp gradlinig und
geschlossen verhalten haben
ich will aber ganz konkret darlegen um
was es bei solidarität mit der ukraine
geht der botschafter ist ja anwesend
meine stadt bochum hat seit 30 jahren
eine partnerschaft mit don jens
seit 30 jahren kämpfen wir dafür dass
mit medikamenten und anderen hilfen die
kinderklinik so versorgt wird dass die
überlebenschancen der ganz kleinen von
mittlerweile nur fünf prozent auf über
80 prozent gestiegen ist das ist
solidarität
partnerschaftlichkeit vor allen dingen
langjährige verlässlichkeit und es
blutet mir wirklich das herz zu sehen
wie es zurzeit fast unmöglich ist durch
die situation die russland zu
verantworten hat in den bass und auch
durch bürokratische schwierigkeiten in
kiew dass wir das nicht immer fortsetzen
können und die stange ausdrücklich der
organisation doktor lisa in moskau die
da behilflich ist dass die medikamente
die
überlebensnotwendigen medikamente auch
tatsächlich in bonn jetzt immer noch ein
stück ankommt
und was
und was russland anbelangt
es gibt nur frieden in europa mit
russland und es gibt auf der anderen
seite die notwendigkeit die wir als
westen das heißt konkret die europäische
union die nato wir als wichtiger teil
als deutsche jetzt gezeigt haben und
sagen wir das auch mal offen das ist
doch viel stärker jetzt als der große
westliche oder nato oder
innereuropäische konflikt zum beispiel
beim irak krieg gewesen ist das doch ein
wichtiger fortschritt und es war
übrigens damals gut
dass wir nicht gefolgt sind als deutsche
bundesregierung damals rot grün uns
beteiligt haben auch eine wichtige
erfahrung auf die wir heute noch einmal
hinweisen müssen denn geschichte hat
kurz mal gesagt und demokratie ist auch
eine frage des guten gedächtnisses und
was das jetzt in der praxis auch
bedeutet ich bin für das russland
monitoring im europarat zuständig nein
ich vertrete deutschland die
sozialdemokratische fraktion einerseits
zusammen mit meiner kollegin ria oomen
räumen die die niederlande die
christdemokraten vertritt es sind ganz
eng beieinander ihn vorgehen wir werden
jetzt in kürze wird er in moskau sein
und wir werden dort mit natürlich der
regierung mit dem gerichtshof mit
oppositionsgruppen mit journalistinnen
und journalisten auch reden um darauf zu
beharren dass die dinge die russland
zugesagt haben auch umgesetzt wird was
menschenrechte was demokratie was an die
diskriminierung anbelangt dafür stehen
wir auch dafür ist es wichtig dass wir
als deutsche in den europäischen
institutionen auch engagiert sind vieles
läuft dort parteiübergreifend das ist
unsere linie die linie des antrags der
cdu/csu können wir nicht mittragen
deshalb lehnen wir ihn ab vielen dank
zu seiner ersten liebe erzählt den
kollegen eugen schmidt das wort
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte damen und herren frau
präsidentin
beatrice kiwi
wollen die russen krieg das sind die
worte aus einem bekannten russischen
lied die antwort ist einfach sicher
nicht genauso wenig wie wir einen krieg
in europa wollen und was möchte die
union
in ihrem antrag spricht sie von einem
dialog mit russland
doch der inhalt offenbar das gegenteil
was sind im antrag stellt wolke die
propaganda nach dem motor börse russen
guter westen
russland wird die alleinige
verantwortung für die aktuellen
spannungen zugeschrieben und
steht ein russische angriff bevor
erst dann sollte doch jeder schon einer
stattfinden aber
wieder nicht
tatsächlich hat sich der westen über
jahrzehnte
arrogant über russische
sicherheitsinteressen
hinweggesetzt der besten wollte nicht
einmal ernsthaft darüber sprechen ja nun
reagiert der russische mehr gereizt
russland wird vorgeworfen die grenzen
anderer staaten mit zu missachten
das kann man so sehen auf der anderen
seite hat die nato die deutsche
beteiligung
1999 serbien angegriffen sie erinnern
sich der erste angriffskrieg der nach
dem ende des zweiten weltkrieges von
deutschen boden ausging
wie vorhin von rot grüner regierung
damals im kosovo-konflikt wurde mit dem
selbstbestimmungsrecht der völker
argumentiert doch bei der creme und den
don was gilt dieser grundsatz offenbar
nicht
doppelmoral
wird hierzu markenzeichen der union
die union stellt nord stream 2 in frage
und somit unsere sichere gas verbindung
gasversorgung
gegen die interessen der usa schwerer
als die des deutschen volkes
es wäre verantwortungslos waffen in
diese region zu schicken der politische
ansatz von cdu und csu wie das spricht
der nationalen und wirtschaftlichen
interessen unseres landes
[Applaus]
gute beziehungen zu russland sind für
den frieden und den wohlstand auf
unserem kontinent
unverzichtbar wir lehnen den antrag der
unionsfraktion ab
herbert jung ski wm
vielen dank
dadurch dass kopfschütteln gesehen beim
botschafter der ukraine in deutschland
bei andrej melik zu diesem beitrag
offensichtlich zu diesem beitrag von
eugen schmidt aus der reifen die
fraktion der hin- und nächster redner in
der liste ist robin wagener kommt aus
der fraktion bündnis 90/die grünen und
ist da sprecher für die angelegenheiten
der europäischen union
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
und liebe kolleginnen und kollegen auf
der linken
das ist doch eine groteske
außenpolitische fehlwahrnehmung was ich
bei ihnen immer wieder beobachten muss
wenn sie die ukraine und die nato für
die außenpolitischen aggressionen
russland und die truppen konzentration
verantwortlich machen wollen was glauben
sie eigentlich wie sie
ansprechpartner für fragen von die
kolonialisierung und antiimperialismus
sein können wenn sie so vollkommen blind
sind für die fortwährenden imperialen
aggressionen und fortwährenden
völkerrechtlichen verletzungen russlands
[Applaus]
und am schlimmsten und das wird in ihrem
antrag deutlich und das am schlimmsten
und gefährlichsten für den aufrichtigen
demokratischen diskurs hier im haus ihr
antrag formuliert gezielte
desinformation wenn sie schreiben dass
die ukraine über 100.000 soldaten und
schwere waffen an der frontlinie im don
was zusammen zieht es sind vielleicht
informationen die sie ausraster today
haben aber nicht aus dem monitoring
berichten der osze sie konstruieren den
vorwurf eines schwerwiegenden bruchs des
minsker abkommens den es auf seiten der
ukraine in der form nicht gibt und die
frage nicht ob sie eigentlich wissen und
deutlich haben besten spielen sie das
spielen wenn sie das machen und das
zeigt wie wichtig die objektiven
beobachtung der osze vor ort sind und
welchen wichtigen beitrag die osze zur
friedenssicherung leistet und da
schließe ich mich ausdrücklich dem dank
der kollegin bürger an die
außenministerin und
liebe linke tun sie sich noch einen
weiteren gefallen überwinden sie endlich
ihre obsession mit der nato und er kennt
sie die tatsachen an 2014 gab es keine
nato mai dann in der ukraine es gab ein
euro mehr an die menschen in der ukraine
sind auf die straße gegangen weil sie
für frieden freiheit und
rechtsstaatlichkeit eingetreten sind und
die orientierung richtige richtung wir
wollten das ist das was die menschen
wollten das ist das wogegen der kreml
seit 2014 mit voller härte vorgeht eine
integration der ukraine in die nato
steht überhaupt nicht auf der
tagesordnung im moment aber wenn die
voraussetzungen erfüllt sind und es ist
noch einen weg dahin aber wenn die
voraussetzungen erfüllt sind dann wird
eines tages der tag kommen an dem die
bürgerinnen und bürger der ukraine
durch ukrainische abgeordnete im
europäischen parlament vertreten sind
und das ist und bleibt das ziel dessen
weg weiter beschreiten wollen und die
wand voraussetzungen arbeiten und habe
über dieses ziel und diesen weg wird
nicht in moskau entschieden sondern in
kiew und in brüssel und überall sonst in
europa
[Applaus]
und jetzt kommen wir zum antrag der
unionsfraktion der antrag zeigt eine
starke euro atlantische allianz die
wichtig ist in diesen fragen und er
zeigt auch dass wir im wesentlichen
grundzügen eine große übereinstimmung in
diesem haus haben was die antwort auf
die russische aggression angeht aber
erstens die klarheit zu nord stream zwei
diesen antrag formulieren die hätten wir
uns vielleicht in der letzten
legislaturperiode auch schon mal
gewünscht und die hätten wir uns auch
von der früheren bundeskanzlerin
gewünscht dann wären manche diskussionen
vielleicht heute nicht so wie sie sind
und
zweitens
zweitens erwarte pool vielleicht
erkundigen sie sich auch mal in der
ukraine und bei ukrainischen militärs
wie dankbar wir dafür sind dass die
bundes außenministerin zu besuch im
militär krankenhaus war wie dankbar sie
dafür sind dass mit deutscher technik
und mit deutscher unterstützung immer
wieder verwundete soldaten behandelt
werden und dass wir ein neues
militärkrankenhaus ein mobiles dahin
liefern weil immer wieder auch heute
immer wieder ein krieg herrscht an der
in der ost ukraine und immer wieder
verwundete soldaten behandelt werden
müssen und das ist grotesk dass nicht
anzuerkennen und da bin ich der
außenministerin sehr dankbar dass sie
mit ihrem besuch in der ost ukraine da
ausdrücklich darauf aufmerksam
aber das hauptproblem des antrags das
ist ein problem dass wir insgesamt im
diskurs haben in ihrem antrag wird die
zusammenarbeit mit der russischen
zivilgesellschaft erst an zehnter stelle
erwähnt wir reden über taktische
bataillone über haubitzen über
panzerverbände artilleriestellung
iskander-raketen blutkonserven und
solche dinge die aussenpolitische
aggression des camps dies aber nur eine
fast hätte der machtsicherung des
apparates im inland wird die repressions
schraube immer enger gegen die
demokratische zivilgesellschaft
angezogen und auch darauf müssen wir
weiter trotz der ablenkungen durch
militärische aggression weiterhin
aufmerksam blick haben wir müssen den
blick darauf werfen wenn die
individuelle repression stattfindet
durch mordanschläge durch willkürliche
haft und terror listen und da ist alexej
nawalny nur ein trauriges prominentes
beispiel wir müssen den blick haben auf
die strukturelle repression wenn mit dem
grotesken vorwurf der ausländischen
agenten kennzeichen wichtige stimmen und
organisationen auf dauer von der
bildfläche verschwinden sollen was sie
im moment besonders deutlich beim
memorial sehen wir müssen den blick
darauf richten wenn der kreml die
deutsche welle schließen lässt nicht
etwa wegen einer vermeintlichen
reaktionen auch dinge die wir hier tun
die schon medienrechtlich quatsch ist
als argumentation sondern weil jegliche
unabhängige berichterstattung in
russland unterdrückt werden soll wenn
man das feindbild über den westen
aufbauen will und die deutsche welle
werdet aber stört und wir müssen den
blick darauf richten und klar benennen
dass der kreml ein diktatorisches regime
in belarus unterstützt das 1061
politische gefangene zu verantworten hat
und kommende woche mit einem legitimen
referendum eine pseudo verfassung ändern
will und gegen den willen der
bevölkerung die herrschaft zementieren
will liebe kolleginnen und kollegen der
truppenaufmarsch schafft eine diskurs
dominanz für den kreml die euro die
aktion richtet sich gegen die
europäische friedensordnung und
wesentlicher teil dieser friedensordnung
ist das friedliche zusammenleben der
völker diesen zivilgesellschaften den
müssen wir unsere aufmerksamkeit widmen
und sie und ihren einsatz müssen wir
unterstützen und damit eine neue
strategische widerstandsfähigkeit gegen
aggression und autokratie entwickeln
vielen dank
[Applaus]
für die fdp-fraktion angereist doch
markus kaya
[Applaus]
der präsidentin liebe kolleginnen
kollegen meine damen und herren wladimir
putin hat seine modernsten
raketensysteme und kampfflugzeuge
nach builder rufus verlegt die beiden
staaten führen dort derzeit das größte
gemeinsame manöver seit dem zerfall der
sowjetunion durch wir haben knapp 150
tausend russische soldaten die an der
ukrainischen grenze konzentriert wurden
wir haben panzer landungsboote im
schwarzen meer die auf ihren auftrag
warten 140 kriegsschiffe der russischen
föderation werden jetzt an ihren übungen
im östlichen mittelmeer und in der
nordsee und in anderen regionen antreten
das alles ist viel aber nicht
deeskalierend die situation ist sehr
ernst und sie müssen wir auch bei sowie
handeln und ich habe die hoffnung dass
wir hier zu einer geschlossenen position
kommen können wenn wir uns auch zwei
prämissen einige die erste ist frieden
ist besser als krieg und die zweite ist
demokratie ist besser als diktatur und
wenn wir uns darauf einigen können dann
habe ich die hoffnung dass wir uns auch
darüber einig sind dass wir da nicht
neutral sein können dass wir nicht
neutral sein können in einer diktatur
ihrer benachbarten demokratie mit krieg
droht wir haben eine moralische
verpflichtung für den frieden in europa
für stabilität in europa und wir haben
auch eine moralische verpflichtung
demokratien in unserer region zu
unterstützen meine damen und herren
und die lage ist leider ernst es ist
auch nicht neu wir haben 2008 erlebt wie
das regime putin in georgien
einmarschiert ist wir haben 2014 erlebt
wie das regime putin die krim besetzt
und einen dauerhaften konflikt in der
ost ukraine provoziert und dann ist es
natürlich auch klar dass wir jetzt hier
ein den aggressor ernst nehmen müssen
dass die ukraine das tun das auch die
baltischen staaten unsere bündnispartner
das tun und dann haben wir als größte
volkswirtschaft im zentrum europas die
verantwortung das auch zu tun und
unseren beitrag zu leisten für frieden
und stabilität in europa und
wir haben dazu drei möglichkeiten wir
haben drei mittel die wir einsetzen
müssen zum ersten diplomatische mittel
um zu deeskalieren deswegen bin ich dem
bundeskanzleramt auch der bundes
außenministerin sehr dankbar dass sie
diese mission in den letzten tagen
umgesetzt und ernst genommen haben und
ich denke da können wir als gesamtes den
beiden auch dankbar sein
wir haben als zweites eine
wirtschaftliche dimension die wir nutzen
müssen wir haben auf der einen seite die
möglichkeit die ukraine zu unterstützen
wer investiert denn in einem land das
permanent von krieg bedroht wird es ist
ja gerade das kalkül von putin hier eine
wirtschaftliche entwicklung und
wohlstand zu verhindern das müssen wir
tun und wir müssen aber auch gegenüber
russland klar machen dass wir die
sanktionen auch klar benennen dass wir
sanktionen benennen damit wir sie nicht
anwenden müssen weil es nicht zu einer
invasion kommt das ist das zweite mittel
und ein drittes kommt dazu ein vorreden
hatte schon erwähnt alle optionen müssen
auf dem tisch liegen das heißt auch wer
den frieden in europa bricht in dem er
einen krieg vom zaun bricht der zerstört
auch die grundlage für die
friedensordnung ja zerstört auch die
grundlage für die nato russland grund
aktion und das ist die anzahl situation
in der wir sind deswegen finde ich es
gut dass die unionsfraktion hat diesen
top aufgesetzt hat ich bin allerdings
nicht ganz so glücklich mit den anträgen
die ich hier von der union sehe von der
opposition sehe bei der linkspartei
bekommen wir viel folklore und russland
verständnis das ist nicht ganz neu die
allianz mit der ard ist ist neu aber
sandro huber dass sie den souveränität
kleineren ländern absprechen das ist
auch nicht neu aber das finde ich
wirklich einfach verantwortungslos was
mich aber links
was mich allerdings wirklich überrascht
hat ist die ist ja unionsantrag die
überschrift des toll geschlossenheit des
westens sind wir alle beieinander aber
ihr mehrseitiger forderungskatalog ist
im wesentlichen eine auflistung der
versäumnisse die sie acht jahre lang in
der regierungsverantwortung aufgetürmt
haben versäumnisse sie acht jahre lang
seit der invasion auf der krim deswegen
lege ich ihnen sich mit ihrem eigenen
forderungskatalog zuerst zu beschäftigen
uns sind solche ergebnisse mitzuteilen
und danach vielleicht diese regierung
jedoch keine 100 tage im amt ist zu
kritisieren vielen dank
markus ferber war das der
verteidigungspolitische sprecher der
fdp-fraktion und nächste redner in
dieser debatte in der es um die haltung
des westens gegenüber russland geht wird
johannes huber sein der bis ende des
jahres mitglied der kfd war auch
mitglied der raf die fraktionen dann ist
er ausgetreten aus beidem und dazu
schreibt die agentur agence france press
von huber sind parteiinterne chat
verläufe auf den messenger-dienst
telegramm aufgetaucht in denen er
antisemitische verschwörung zu
erzählungen gefeuert jetzt ist er also
eher als fraktionsloser am mikrofon aber
putin muss anerkennen dass die
mitgliedstaaten nach 1997 dem bündnis
aus freier selbstbestimmung
beigetreten sind und der warschauer pakt
nicht mehr existiert wenn putin in
seinem vertragsentwürfen über
sicherheitsgarantien faktisch ein ende
der nato fordert und die stationierung
jeglicher ausländischer truppen in den
vierzehn mitgliedstaaten und das sagt
dann ist eine solche garantie
unrealistisch und nicht im deutschen
interesse
anders verhält es sich bei der forderung
eine weitere ausweitung der nato auf
georgien und die ukraine zu unterbinden
das ersuchen des ukrainischen
präsidenten sie denn ziel den bis heute
anhaltenden bürgerkrieg in der ost
ukraine mit einem nato-beitritt zu lösen
muss das bündnis verbindlich absagen es
liegt weder im deutschen noch im
eurasischen
die nato als konfliktpartei in den
ukrainischen bürgerkrieg mit anderen
stellvertreter konfliktpartei russland
hineinzuziehen das wäre die auslösung
eines flächenbrandes den viele bürger
als dritter weltkrieg befürchten
angesichts einer militärischen
niederlage der ukraine im falle einer
russischen invasion liegt es auch im
ukrainischen interesse am ennskai
abkommen festzuhalten und das normandie
format auszubauen
friedliche verhandlungen ohne
angelsächsische beteiligung haben 2015
die ukrainische armee vor einem
zusammenbruch gerettet wenn ich hier
heute einen krieg verhindern und
obendrauf die vollständige kontrolle
über die staatsgrenze wieder erhalten
möchte dann muss die lenski den punkt 9
aus dem minsker abkommen umsetzen und
mit den vertretern der oberste donetsk
und luhansk regionalwahlen und eine
verfassungsreform abstimmen
von dieser entscheidung über dialog oder
konfrontation hängt ab ob ganz europa
das risiko eines flächenbrandes eingeht
oder nicht vielen dank
nina scheer spricht jetzt für die
spd-fraktion
und nina scheer ist sprecherin für
klimaschutz und energie und beim thema
energie und russland fällt uns natürlich
eine gewisse pipeline ein
paar präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen die situation an der
russisch-ukrainischen grenze ist eine
bedrohung für die sicherheit und in
frieden in europa insofern bin ich der
bundesregierung und insbesondere
bundeskanzler olaf scholz dankbar für
die in den letzten tagen erreichten
zeichen der entspannung
dies zeigt dass es sich bewährt auf
diplomatie zu setzen und sich auch nicht
zu eskalierenden schritten an treiben zu
lassen und das sage ich auch
ausdrücklich in richtung cdu csu hervor
es ist nicht auszumalen wie sich die
lage entwickelt hätte wenn etwa dem ruf
nach waffenlieferungen nach gegeben
worden wäre
jenseits der akuten bedrohung und ich
betone jenseits wie sie von den
militärischen aufmärschen russlands
ausgeht gilt es eine betrachtung
objektiver sicherheitsinteressen aller
beteiligter in den blick zu nehmen im
kontext völkerrechtlicher gegebenheiten
auch solcher denn natürlich solcher der
ukraine der eu der usa aber eben auch
auf russischer seite die bundeskanzler
olaf scholz in moskau klar gestellt hat
ist es unsere verdammte pflicht und
aufgabe verdammt wurde aus dem protokoll
gestrichen aber ich fand den griff ich
den begriff unsere verdammte pflicht und
aufgabe unserer generation
dass krieg in europa ausgeschlossen wird
in diesem sinne
und wie sie senden möchte ich aber auch
noch über eine weitere bedrohungslage
eingehen die innerhalb dieses aktuellen
konflikts bürger wird aber auch über den
konflikt hinausgeht es ist auch eine
sicherheitspolitische aufgabe die
weltweite abhängigkeit von fossilen
energieressourcen und dazu gehört
übrigens auch programm durch den
schnellstmöglichen umstieg auf
erneuerbare energien zu überwinden im
falle einer militärischen eskalation
könnte eben diese abhängigkeit zu einer
existenziellen gefahr durch energie
versorgungs nöte werden neben den
bekannten klima folgeschäden sind das
explodierende energiepreise die die
heutigen preissprünge um ein vielfaches
übersteigen werden und werden dies
letztere wären dann eben auch die folge
knapp 55 prozent des in deutschland
verbrauchten gases
wären
knapp 55 prozent des in deutschland
verbrauchten erdgases kommen aus
russland
aber etwa auch die usa beziehen öl aus
russland neben aktuell maßnahmen zur
vorhaltung gefüllte gasspeicher und
einer künftigen gewährleistung
entsprechend der füllstände ist es
richtig und wichtig eine strategische
reserve in staatlicher gewehr zu
schaffen den energieversorgung ist
daseinsvorsorge und darf weder zum
spekulationsobjekt noch zum erpressungs
instrument werden auch wenn russland zu
jenem zeitpunkt zu jedem zeitpunkt
selbst in kalten krieg geschlossene
lieferverträge eingehalten hat wir
müssen uns vor augen führen diese 55
prozent unserer abhängigkeit
können kurzfristig und kurzfristig ist
dort durchaus über jahres spannend zu
betrachten nicht ersetzt werden auch
nicht durch elektiven lieferungen
bereits die weltmarkt getriebene
energiepreisentwicklung führt aktuell
zur ökonomischen und sozialen härten auf
die auch reagiert wird mit heizkosten
zuschüssen und auch eine absenkung der
eeg umlage ist derzeit endprüfung die
maßnahmen verdeutlichen aber auch dass
sie nur für absolute ausnahmefälle und
zur abfederung geleistet werden können
um energiesicherheit zu gewährleisten
brauchen wir den beschleunigten und
systemischen umstieg auf erneuerbare
energie und zwar schnell verknüpft mit
speichern darunter
ist ein sicherheits die
friedenspolitische auftrag auch für ein
continental für einen kontinental
europäischen verbund übrigens dass die
bezahlbarkeit von energie nur durch
erneuerbare energien zu garantieren ist
haben wir letztes wochenende gesehen am
sonntag wurden 95 prozent des
strombedarfs über erneuerbare energien
gedeckt und das hat auch an den worten
strompreisen sich ausgewirkt waren
billig wie noch nie in frankreich
übrigens nicht bei dem atomstrom anteil
der dort zu verzeichnen die koalition
hat sich diese energiewende zum ziel
gesetzt und arbeitet unter hochdruck
daran ich schließe mit den worten
friedenspolitik ist auch eine
energiewende politik
mission aus der spd fraktionssprecherin
für klimaschutz und energie war die
drittletzte rednerin in dieser debatte
zur haltung des westens zur politik
russland das lineare anträge aus der afg
aus der linksfraktion und der
unionsfraktion zugrunde und aus der
union kommt auch der nächste redner
reinhard brandl wird da sein mitglied im
verteidigungsausschuss
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin verehrte kolleginnen
und kollegen zu zeiten des warschauer
pakt war die ukraine immer
wirtschaftlich stärker als ihr nachbar
polen nach dem zusammenbruch des
warschauer pakts ging's für polen steil
nach oben sie haben ihre
wirtschaftskraft in der zeit fast
verzehnfacht werden sich die ukraine wo
auf einem niedrigen niveau langsam nach
oben entwickelt dieser vergleich zeigt
die wahre bedrohung von russland von
putins russland wenn die ukraine einen
ähnlichen weg nehmen würde wie polen ihn
genommen hat dann könnte er in seinem
land die geschichte der überlegenheit
des russischen systems nicht mehr weiter
erzählen und er will deswegen um jeden
preis die annäherung der ukraine an
europa verhindern aber das allein reicht
eben nicht mit dem dritten aufzug den
wir im moment an der grenze zur ukraine
sehen will er vor allem die nato und
europa spalten das ist ein strategisches
ziel es geht nicht nur um die ukraine es
geht vor allem auch um uns und das muss
uns bewusst
mit der ankündigung mit der konkreten
ankündigung eines krieges will er uns
zwingen unsere eigenen werte zu verraten
und ihm das recht zuzugestehen über
andere länder zu bestimmen und zu
herrschen und er hat jetzt an der grenze
alles zusammen gezogen was er dafür
braucht und er wird dann mitspielen
monatelang jahre lang wir haben es doch
jetzt gerade in diesen tagen erlebt am
wochenende kündigte oder lässt er einen
aufmacher einmarsch für mittwoch planen
erhöht damit massiv den druck am
mittwoch letzte trocken wieder raus in
dem auch kündigt truppen truppen
zurückzuziehen und er wird dieses spiel
weiterspielen und wenn er sieht dass wir
unter diesem druck auseinanderbrechen
dann wird er den druck erhöhen immer
weiter nur wenn er sieht dass wir das
mehr druck nur teurer für ihn wird dann
wird das und deswegen ist die
strategische und große herausforderung
für uns wie es auch in unserem antrag
formuliert ist dass wir den druck
entgegen wirken dass wir uns nicht
spalten lassen und im bündnis
entschlossen und geschlossen wirken und
meine damen und herren ich finde es gut
ausdrücklich dass bundeskanzler scholz
in kiew in moskau und den russen in
washington aber ich hätte es auch sehr
gut gefunden wenn er heute hier im
deutschen bundestag seine politik
erklärt hatte und die zweifel an der
geschlossenheit und entschlossenheit der
deutschen bündnistreue mit der tt wir
stehen natürlich fragen wie hält es die
neue bundesregierung mit den zwei herzen
in der nato
sie haben die anderen fragen warum kommt
wahrscheinlich ich muss sie aber fragen
ob sie den inzwischen fragen bis hin zu
lassen möchten ich würde sie nicht
zulassen und im winter die
kurzintervention zustimmen das ist jetzt
nicht in ihrem das kann ja bist und
bitten und ich kann überlegen habe ich
zulassen oder nicht aber jetzt erstmal
sondern heute
ich war bei olaf scholz hätte nämlich
fragen klären müssen er hätte ich waren
klären soll die im raum stehen wie hält
es die bundesregierung mit dem zwei
prozent ziel der nato wie hält es die
aktuelle bundesregierung mit slim 2 wie
hält es die aktuelle bundesregierung mit
dem selbstverteidigungsrecht der ukraine
in dem er diesen fragen kontinuierlich
ausweiten
und versteht er zweifel im bündnis und
nimmt die glaubwürdigkeit unseres
beitrags die unsere partner erwarten uns
erwarten natürlich von uns mehr als 5000
hinten jetzt war ich auch dafür ein
konkretes beispiel zu nennen oder ich
war auch dagegen dass man der ukraine
helme dass nur der ukraine waffen
liefert aber dann hätte man es auch klar
benennen soll und nicht die
bundesverteidigungsministerium prüft
prüfen lassen und dazu im ergebnis zu
kommen wir könnten gar nicht mehr
liefern das macht uns unglaubwürdig das
ist auch falsch und schadet der
bundeswehr und schadet und bedient genau
das narrativ der fehlenden
entschlossenheit unglaubwürdigkeit
deutschland und meine damen und herren
der bundeskanzler hätte heute auch die
chance nutzen müssen um sich von seinem
unseligen amtsvorgänger gerhard schröder
hier zu distanzieren
er hat schröder wird aus russland
bezahlt er ist ein schwere belastung für
die diplomatie deutschland und ich würde
mir wünschen meine lieben kolleginnen
und kollegen von der sozialdemokratie
dass sie in den haushaltsverhandlungen
unseren antrag folge die mittel für das
büro von gerhard schröder hier in diesem
haus zu streichen
sie müssen sich umgehend keine sorgen
machen er bekommt genügend geld als muss
man er ist gut versorgt er braucht den
deutschen steuerzahler nicht für sie
wäre es aber eine chance haltung zu
zeigen und für deutschland wäre es eine
chance für politische hygiene herzlichen
dank für ihre aufmerksamkeit
das war der redebeitrag von reinhard
brandl jetzt schauen wir mal was jetzt
an kurzinterventionen noch kommt
für die spd fraktion
keine prävention mehr also jetzt die
erste rede von adis adrovic aus der spd
fraktion
sehr freundlich sehr geehrte frau
präsidentin meine damen und herren es
ist mir eine große ehre heute hier und
jetzt vor ihnen zu stehen und als junger
abgeordneter zur außen- und
sicherheitspolitik deutschland zu
sprechen das thema aber zu dem ich heute
meine erste rede halten darf ist ein
sehr besorgniserregend und sehr
bedrohlich ist die gefahr eines krieges
auf europäischen boden ist so groß wie
seit den 90er jahren nicht mehr mehrere
generationen in der eu und in weiten
teilen europas sind mit der abwesenheit
von krieg aufgewachsen
frieden ist für sie etwas
selbstverständliches auch wenn wir immer
wieder davon ausgehen mussten dass es zu
kriegerischen auseinandersetzungen
kommen kann und das sehen wir gerade im
aktuellen rog eine konflikt diese immer
größer werdende gefahr eines
militärischen konflikt nehmen die
menschen unseres landes war täglich
bekommen wir viele zuschriften die
menschen fordern uns auf für stabilität
und frieden zu sorgen und das meine
damen und herren dürfen die menschen
auch zu recht erwarten eine liberale
demokratie so wie es die bundesrepublik
deutschland ist wie sie lebt und auch
ausfüllt
hat den auftrag unbeirrbar für frieden
und stabilität in europa zu sorgen
wir müssen jeden diplomatischen schritte
bis zum letzten ausreizen die türen für
die friedliche beendigung dieses
konfliktes bis zum schluss offen halten
ohne dass wir unsere werte aufgeben
keine seite
wird aus diesem konflikt als gewinner
hervorgehen deshalb wollen wir keinen
krieg sondern frieden mit diplomatie
auch wenn der weg der diplomatie oft
steinig ist und von einigen als zeichen
der schwäche nachgiebigkeit oder
nachsichtigkeit gegenüber russland
verstanden wird in diesem fall ist die
diplomatie der einzig richtige weg und
ein klares signal für mut und
entschlossenheit
ich bin davon überzeugt dass jeder hass
und jede form von gewalt ausgehend von
autokratien und diktaturen niemals aber
wirklich niemals stärker sein werden als
die kraft der demokratie und das
zusammenspiel aller demokratischer
staaten in europa
um es aber mit aller deutlichkeit zu
sagen damit hier keine missverständnisse
aufkommen sollte es durch russland eine
neue militärische aggression gegen die
ukraine geben die ehre territoriale
integrität und souveränität weiter
untergräbt muss russland mit harten
sanktionen und reaktionen rechnen die
wir gemeinsam und geschlossen
mit unseren verbündeten in europa und in
der nato umgehend verabschieden werden
und deshalb bin ich dankbar dass wir
über diese akute bedrohungslage heute
wieder im parlament sprechen und ich bin
mir sicher dass wir uns alle einig sind
was das ziel angeht wir wollen keinen
krieg
in der ukraine wir wollen frieden in
ganz europa anders aber als die
oppositionsparteien sagen wir als
regierungsfraktionen wir werden einen
anderen weg wir reagieren nicht mit
gegen aggressionen auf aggressionen oder
stehen uns partei stellen uns partei auf
die seite russlands wir kommen nämlich
nur dann einen schritt voran wenn wir
alle verhandlungspartner auf augenhöhe
begegnen und ich bin froh dass wir einen
kanzler wie olaf scholz haben eine
außenministerin wie annalena baerbock
den vergangenen tagen und wochen einmal
mehr bewiesen was besonnenheit und ruhe
auswirken kann in der internationalen
politik dieser erfolg der letzten tage
ist ein erfolg von anna-lena derbe und
von olaf scholz seine damen
und beide haben es ganz klar gezeigt
dialog und diplomatie haben sie auf eine
neue positive qualität gesetzt und sie
haben auch noch gezeigt dass es aus
schöpfen das potenzial gibt
einhaltung und vollständige umsetzung
des abkommens
rüstungskontrolle zwischen der nato und
russland
vereinbarte kontinuierliche dialoge im
nato-russland-rat sowie im nummern die
format und auch zivilgesellschaftliche
lösungen wie eine visa liberalisierung
für junge russinnen russen um den
austausch zwischen ost und west
voranzutreiben und was wir für die
zukunft brauchen und daran müssen wir in
den nächsten jahren aktiv und intensiv
arbeiten meine damen und herren ist eine
gemeinsame sicherheits struktur und
architektur bei der wir russland nicht
ausschließen meine damen und herren wenn
wir jetzt mit unseren diplomatischen
bemühungen scheitern wird die steigende
anspannung zu einem dominoeffekt führen
und zu einem brandbeschleuniger für
andere konflikte in europa wie zum
beispiel westbalkan und herr gysi ich
schätze sie eigentlich wenn aber
fassungslos überaus führung gewesen ich
würde sie gerne mal mit neben den
westlichen balkan ob kroatien montenegro
bosnien und lassen sie uns mal schauen
was zwischen 1991 bis 99 passiert ist
über 200.000 tote hat der
jugoslawienkrieg ausgelöst und hätte man
nicht agiert 99 wäre das eine
fortsetzung des morgens gewesen ist aber
dass eine richtige entscheidung das hat
olaf scholz auch klar gemacht in moskau
zum schluss richtig farbe kommt meine
redezeit ist zu ende
sowohl in der ukraine als auch in
montenegro oder in boston offener oder
anderswo in europa
wenn es zu grenzverschiebungen kommen
sollte werden wir das nicht hinnehmen
und deshalb lassen sie uns gemeinsam
vereint die stärke und strahlkraft
dieses parlamentes nutzen um den frieden
und die freiheit in europa zu
verteidigen es schlägt die stunde der
diplomatie von friedenspolitik vielen
dank für ihre aufmerksamkeit
habe sehr gemischte am metro wird pardon
mit seiner ersten rede im deutschen
bundestag in der debatte in der es um
die haltung des westens zur politik
russlands ging
von storch sie würde ich herzlich bitten
zu ihrem schutz und dem der anderen
dankeschön die macht richtig zu tragen
ich schließe die aussprache und wir
kommen zur abstimmung über den antrag
der fraktion der cdu/csu auf 36 92 mit
dem titel russlands politik mit der
geschlossenheit des westens
entgegentreten wer stimmt für diesen
antrag
das ist die cdu csu fraktion wir stimmt
dagegen
das sind
alle übrigen fraktionen
er möchte sich enthalten
enthaltungen sehe ich keine herzlichen
dank damit ist dieser antrag abgelehnt
und den anderen anträge die hier
diskutiert worden sind nämlich aus der
fdp-fraktion und aus der fraktion die
linke die werden überwiesen oder sollen
überwiesen werden beispielsweise an den
auswärtigen ausschuss und
das ist das verfahren dass jetzt gerade
im hintergrund passiert und dass katrin
göring eckardt die
bundestags-vizepräsidentin leitet so